.
* Trommelklänge, singende Kinder *
Dschibuti, Ostafrika.
Das ist die Wahlheimat
von Cornelia Frey.
Die Bernerin hat grosse Pläne,
aber wenig finanzielle Mittel.
Der Gedanke: "Das geht nicht, ich
muss überleben" ist schweizerisch.
Das habe ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe keine Existenzängste.
Als Regisseurin realisiert sie
mit Einheimischen Filme.
Sie komponiert, singt Lieder
und ist beseelt von einer Mission:
Hier in dieser Gesellschaft
läuft ziemlich viel etwas schräg.
Lügen, Betrügereien,
jeder schaut, was er bekommt.
Das will ich den Leuten
etwas unter die Nase halten,
sodass sie sich
darüber Gedanken machen.
Weshalb wandert eine Schweizerin
nach Afrika aus?
Wie sieht ihr Alltag aus?
Und wie verwirklicht sich jemand
in einem der ärmsten Länder der Welt?
Davon handelt diese Reportage.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Cornelia Freys Geschichte beginnt im
bernischen Langenthal in diesem Haus.
Hier verbrachte sie ihre Jugend, hier
wuchsen auch ihre drei Kinder auf.
Einmal im Jahr kommt sie jeweils
zurück zu ihren Wurzeln.
Hast du dieses Bild schon gesehen?
Die geschiedene Auswanderin
besucht ihre Mutter Trudy Frey,
die noch immer hier wohnt.
Zu Gast ist auch Sohn Silas Bitterli,
ein Künstler.
In Afrika
war der 32-Jährige noch nie.
Er lebt seine Abenteuerlust
in selbst gemalten Bildern aus.
Meines ist ungefährlich ...
- Aber meines ist Fantasie ...
Da kannst du nicht irgendwie ...
Ich könnte das nie.
Ich wusste,
ich würde irgendwann gehen.
Wann wusstest du das?
Das wüsste ich wirklich gerne.
Ich hatte es immer im Hinterkopf.
Wenn es ganz schlimm war,
mir die Decke auf den Kopf fiel,
stellte ich einfach die Wohnung um.
(Lachend) Ach, darum!
- Ja ...
Das wusste ich nicht. Plötzlich war
die Wohnung anders eingerichtet.
Ich kam von der Schule und die
Hälfte war an einem anderen Ort -
ich fand das lustig.
Ich stellte mein Zimmer um,
wenn ich mich anders fühlte,
aber ich wusste nicht,
dass das bei dir auch so war.
Sie hat sich das irgendwie
selbst bewiesen.
Seit sie klein ist,
macht sie, was sie will.
(Lachend) Seit sie klein ist.
Ich habe tolle Kinder grossgezogen,
stand in der Nacht auf 20-mal auf,
wechselte Windeln -
ich mache nicht nur, was ich will.
Nein, aber du setzt deinen Kopf
durch, das meine ich.
Das musst du ja auch.
Nur diese Vorstellung:
"Ich gebe hier alles auf,
habe keine finanzielle Sicherheit
mehr, gehe einfach dorthin."
"Ich lerne mal die Sprache,
dann schaue ich mal, was ich mache."
Ich könnte das nicht.
Ich hatte hier immer alles,
als ich aufwuchs.
Sie hatten ein Geschäft, wir hatten
immer Essen, Spielzeug, Kleider.
Das ist die Schweiz.
- Ja, wir hatten alles.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
im Luxus zu leben.
Als es bei Freunden Diskussionen
gab, welche Farbe, welche Automarke
sie kaufen wollen, dachte ich mir:
"Jetzt reicht's aber."
"Es muss noch eine andere Welt
geben, ich will mehr sehen."
* Trommelklänge, singende Kinder *
Tadjoura am gleichnamigen Golf
im Kleinstaat Dschibuti.
Die Ortschaft zählt 22'000 Einwohner
und ein Vielfaches an Ziegen.
Die Menschen hier sind Muslime.
Sie gehören zum Volk der Afar.
Seit zehn Jahren lebt Cornelia Frey
auf dem schwarzen Kontinent.
Nur wenige der hiesigen Menschen
beherrschen eine Fremdsprache.
Deshalb war es für sie ein Muss,
die Sprache der Afar zu lernen.
* Sie spricht Afar. *
Die Fähre
legt nur zweimal pro Woche an.
Die Zufahrtstrasse ist schlecht
ausgebaut und oft nicht befahrbar.
Sie ist die einzige Weisse
im abgelegenen Ort.
Ich habe Glück,
dass ich schon älter bin.
Der Respekt vor älteren Frauen
ist schon vorhanden.
Ja.
Wäre ich jetzt 20,
würde ich dauernd angebaggert,
das wäre schwierig.
Aber jetzt ist es kein Problem.
Dschibuti
ist ein stark unterentwickeltes Land.
Das Gesundheitssystem und
die Infrastruktur liegen am Boden.
Mehr als 60 % der Bevölkerung
haben keine Arbeit.
Die Leute, die wir gesehen haben,
werden nachts
mit Schiffen und Bussen
weitergefahren nach Jemen.
Durch den Krieg
bis nach Saudi-Arabien.
Also Flüchtlinge?
- Nein, das sind clandestins.
D.h., sie wollen arbeiten gehen,
also quasi Arbeitsflüchtlinge.
Und Sie flüchten aus der Schweiz
hierher, nach Dschibuti?
Ich bin nicht geflüchtet.
Es war ein freiwilliger Entschluss.
Für andere wäre das fast eine Strafe.
- Wie?
Für andere wäre das
fast eine Strafe.
Ja, das kann sein.
Regiert wird der Kleinstaat
durch ein autoritäres Regime.
Was gefällt Ihnen besonders hier?
Äh ... Das Meer ist schön.
Aber sonst
gefällt mir eigentlich nicht viel,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin eher hier, um die Situation
der Menschen zu verändern.
Aber jetzt müssen wir weiter.
Cornelia Frey versucht sich hier
als Künstlerin zu etablieren.
U.a. macht sie Musik.
Dabei bezieht sie
die einheimische Bevölkerung mit ein.
Er schreibt Texte für Lieder.
Ich fragte ihn, ob er für uns zu
einem Thema etwas schreiben könnte.
Dadurch erhielt er einen Job,
hat etwas zu tun
und fühlt sich bestätigt.
* Elektronische Reggae-Klänge *
Dieses Stück hat die Schweizerin
zusammen mit Einheimischen
komponiert und arrangiert.
Leider ist ihr Video
weder im Fernsehen zu sehen
noch im Radio zu hören.
Denn - sie will Geld dafür.
Meine Idee ist, unsere Sachen zu
produzieren und ihnen zu verkaufen.
Wenn ich es am Anfang gratis gebe,
können wir nie etwas verkaufen.
In diesem Haus wohne ich,
im ersten Stock.
Hinter der heutigen Künstlerin liegt
eine abwechslungsreiche Karriere:
Kochlehre, Wirteprüfung,
Handelsdiplom,
kaufmännische Angestellte.
Als ihre Kinder flügge wurden,
liess sie das Leben in Wohlstand
hinter sich und zog nach Afrika.
Hier kommt sie
mit monatlich 400 Fr. aus.
Trotzdem sind finanzielle Engpässe
ein Dauerthema.
Sie haben ja fast Ihr ganzes Geld
aufgebraucht, auch die Pensionskasse.
Ja, das ist futsch.
Aber ich habe erlebt,
dass ich immer genug Geld hatte,
auch wenn ich jetzt
alles verbraucht habe.
Dieses Vertrauen habe ich.
Ich bin jetzt
seit zehn Jahren so unterwegs
und alles hat extrem geklappt.
Ja.
Ich habe eher Gottvertrauen
als Schiss -
würde ich meinen.
C'est bon?
Die Schweizerin
ist eine Überlebenskünstlerin.
Ihr fällt immer etwas ein, um ein
paar Dschibuti-Francs zu verdienen.
Woher sind diese Instrumente?
Die habe ich
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht.
Mhm. Und was machen Sie damit?
Wir vermieten sie.
Es findet eine Hochzeit statt.
Die Männer sitzen stundenlang
zusammen und machen Musik.
Ich kann die Instrumente vermieten.
Er spielt Klavier, verdient etwas.
Und Sie verdienen auch etwas?
- Ich verdiene dabei.
Ich kann das Material vermieten.
Es ist eine Win-win-Situation.
* Elektronische Reggae-Klänge *
Tadjoura hat
als zweitgrösste Stadt des Landes
nur gerade zwei Einkaufsläden.
Im unfruchtbaren Dschibuti
müssen selbst Lebensmittel
wie Gemüse und Früchte
importiert werden.
Mandarinen
gibt es etwa alle zwei Monate.
Deshalb kaufe ich jetzt welche.
Das ist alles an Gemüse,
was es gibt. Zitronen gibt es auch.
Sie müssen mal
den Salat dort anschauen.
* Sie sprechen miteinander. *
Viele Münzen.
* Trommelklänge, singende Kinder *
Dschibuti ist seit drei Jahren
Cornelia Freys Heimat.
Zuvor lebte sie sieben Jahre lang
in Äthiopien.
Dort gründete sie ein Kinderheim.
Es sind jetzt 40 Kinder dort.
Am Anfang waren es nur wenige,
die Leute hatten Angst, sie
zu mir in die Schule zu schicken.
Jetzt habe ich dort
zwölf angestellte Lehrer.
Sie gehen morgens
in die öffentliche Schule.
Am Nachmittag habe ich sechs Lehrer,
die sie unterrichten.
Das Kinderheim in Äthiopien
wird durch Spendengelder finanziert.
Einen Lohn beziehe sie keinen,
sagt Cornelia Frey.
Sie ist zwar nach wie vor
die Leiterin,
doch vor Ort ist sie nur noch selten.
Grund:
die Terrororganisation al-Shabaab.
Al-Shabaab ist gekommen.
Sie waren ca. 1 1/2 Std.
von Ayssaita entfernt,
wo meine Schule ist.
Sie erschossen am Morgen Frauen
und Kinder, als die schliefen.
Beunruhigt Sie das nicht? Finden Sie
nicht, Sie leben gefährlich?
Als sie dann alle,
die angeschossen wurden,
ca. 50 Menschen, nach Ayssaita
ins Spital gebracht haben,
war mir auch nicht mehr wohl.
Bisher war es immer
etwas weiter weg,
Richtung Addis Abeba,
im Hafengebiet.
Dort sind Somali und Afar.
Dort kriselt es seit Jahren.
Jetzt hat es stark zugenommen,
zwischendurch
sind die Strassen gesperrt.
Dort weiss man,
dass es immer wieder knallt.
Aber jetzt kam es plötzlich
von der anderen Seite.
Da dachte ich: Jetzt ist mir
auch nicht mehr wohl.
Gut, ich bin in der Stadt.
Aber ich dachte schon:
Jetzt gehe ich wieder nach Dschi-
buti, bis sich die Lage beruhigt.
* Trommelklänge, singende Kinder *
In Dschibuti fand die Lebenskünst-
lerin eine neue Herausforderung.
Nebst ihren Musikprojekten realisiert
sie mit Einheimischen Soaps.
Sie filmt und bearbeitet ihre Werke
gleich selber.
Er kann nicht schlafen,
weil er an sie denken muss.
Er hat sich völlig verliebt.
Auch das Lied handelt davon.
In dieser Szene treffen sie sich
zum ersten Mal, beim Kaffee,
im Restaurant
draussen auf der Strasse.
Sie treffen sich zum ersten Mal
und verlieben sich gleich.
Wie das Gespräch zu- und hergeht,
ist ziemlich interessant.
Haben Sie sich hier in Afrika
eigentlich auch schon verliebt?
Ich?
- Ja.- Nein.
Sie haben keinen Partner?
- Nein.
Woran liegt es?- An den Menschen.
Das passt gar nicht.
Die Idee ist anders.
Liebe, sich verlieben
wie wir in der Schweiz
ist nicht dasselbe.
Sie denken einfach an ihren Vorteil.
Wenn sich mir jemand nähert,
ist der Gedanke:
"Dann komme ich weg von hier,
dann komme ich nach Europa."
Oder:
"Die hat viel Geld, also ansaugen."
Es geht dabei nicht um mich.
Das suche ich nicht.
Ui-ui-ui.
Hier haben wir ein Tuch.
Eigentlich wären heute weitere
Dreharbeiten ihrer Romanze geplant.
Das ist eine Naturkatastrophe,
wir können uns nicht aufregen.
Oder?
Ist das eine Naturkatastrophe?
Für hier schon, oder?- Ja.
Das ist doch eine, wenn man
wegen der Natur nicht filmen kann.
Das ist doch eine Naturkatastrophe.
Es ist unangenehm,
wenn es einem ins Haus regnet, oder?
Ja, es ist scheisse.
Man muss aufräumen.
Dabei hätte ich zu tun,
ich müsste noch Aufnahmen mixen.
Noch zig Dinge.
Aber so kann man nichts machen.
Die Farbe fällt ab.
In dieser Jahreszeit regnet es
eigentlich nicht so.- Nein.
Es ist schräg,
dass es derart regnet.
Und so heftig.
Am nächsten Tag:
* Gesprächsfetzen, Motorgeräusche *
Ich gehe die eine Schauspielerin
suchen, denn sie hat kein Telefon.
Ich habe versucht, sie anzurufen,
denn wir möchten heute Nachmittag
eine Szene drehen.
Ich muss sie wohl suchen gehen,
sie kommt nicht von allein.
Er sagt, die Strasse sei zu wenig
gut, wir müssten zu Fuss gehen.
* Sie sprechen Afar. *
Kamera ein, bitte.
Hier lebt diese Schauspielerin?
- Sie kommt gleich.
Ja, das ist ihr Zuhause.
Gestern hat es geregnet,
es ist alles ...
* Sie spricht Afar. *
Es ist alles kaputtgegangen.
Das war wohl auch eine Hütte.
Vom Regen?
- Ja.
Die Laienschauspielerin wohnt
in einem gemauerten Haus ohne Dach.
Die 17-jährige Safiya Ali Hassan
ist die Hauptdarstellerin
in der Miniserie.
Cornelia Frey bespricht mit ihr
den heutigen Drehtag.
* Sie sprechen Afar. *
Sie lebt in grosser Armut.
- Ja, extrem.
Es ist eben mein Ziel,
solche Menschen zu holen
und ihnen zu helfen,
einen Job zu geben,
sodass sie
z.B. Strom installieren könnten.
Das habe ich ihr
vorhin schon gesagt.
Strom soll Safiya
als Nächstes erhalten.
Die Schweizerin unterstützte sie
schon oft.
Ich schaute, dass sie in
Dschibuti ein paar Monate
zur Schule konnte, weil sie
die Schule abgebrochen hat.
Die beiden Frauen kennen sich
seit zwei Jahren.
Aufgrund der Dreharbeiten
sehen sie sich häufig.
Cornelia lebt zwar
noch nicht lange hier,
aber sie versteht unsere Tradition.
Unterwegs zum heutigen Drehort.
Jetzt drehen wir eine Szene
in einem Garten,
wo man die Tür schliessen kann,
weil viele Kinder kommen.
Wir müssen alles ändern.
Sie haben Angst vor der Kamera.
Die Darstellerinnen setzen
Cornelia Freys Ideen spontan um.
Ein Drehbuch gibt es nicht.
Meistens ist die Szene
nach dem ersten Versuch im Kasten.
Es sei denn,
Zaungäste stören die Aufnahmen.
Ich würde gerne ein Star werden
und viel Geld verdienen.
Ich machte ihnen nie Hoffnungen,
falsche schon gar nicht.
Ich sagte einfach,
dass wir einen Film machen
und sie mithelfen können,
wenn sie möchten.
Ich wäre froh, es wäre cool
und sie würden etwas verdienen.
Aber die Erwartungen sind da,
berühmt und reich zu werden.
Das sehe ich.
Ich höre das zum ersten Mal,
das haben sie mir nie gesagt.
Aber es ist klar:
Sie werden berühmt.
Die nächste Szene.
Gespielt wird ein Streit
zwischen Safiya und ihrem Mann.
* Rülpsen *
Er hat ihr ein Leben
in Saus und Braus versprochen.
Jetzt stellt sich heraus,
dass er Schulden hat.
Safiya fühlt sich hintergangen.
Eine Szene, die typisch sei
für Dschibuti, betont die Bernerin.
Sie versteht sich als Aufklärerin.
Da kommt eine Schweizerin,
um ihnen zu zeigen, was falsch läuft.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
- Ja ...
Jeder Mensch hat
eine andere Sicht der Dinge.
Wie hier gelogen und betrogen wird,
so etwas habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Wenn man in einer Gesellschaft lebt,
in der man so aufgewachsen ist,
sieht man das gar nicht.
Dann braucht es manchmal
andere von aussen, die das zeigen.
"He, geh raus,
du störst die Aufnahmen",
sagt sie zum nächsten Störenfried.
Was ist mit dem, der hier schläft?
Stört er?
Die lacht die ganz Zeit.
* Sie spricht Afar. *
"Hau ab, verschwinde",
sagt Safiya zu ihrem Mann.
"Ich lasse mich von dir scheiden."
Wir machen die Szene
besser in meinem Haus.
Die wird noch ewig grölen.
Der gespielte Streit mündet draussen
für die 17-jährige Schauspielerin
in einer reale Belästigung.
Wir machten schon Aufnahmen, bei
denen er sich fast auf sie legte.
Man konnte sie fast nicht trennen -
furchtbar.
Wir haben die Episode
mit ihm angefangen.
Jetzt brauchte ich eine Lösung,
um ihn loszuwerden.
Durch die Scheidung ist er weg?
- Ja, jetzt haben wir Ruhe.
Eine kleine Siedlung
ist Schauplatz der nächsten Szene.
Jetzt ruft sie ihn an, er ist hier.
Er soll morgen zu ihr kommen,
sie muss ihm etwas sagen. That's it.
* Sie spricht Afar. *
* Er spricht Afar. *
Ihr dreht die fünfte Staffel, seid
aber immer noch nicht im Fernsehen.
Warum nicht?- Weil wir es ihnen
noch nicht gezeigt haben.
Wir machen jetzt einige Staffeln,
dann zeigen wir es dem Fernsehen.
Es gab einen neuen Chef.
Der vorherige hatte kein Geld mehr,
weil er alles verbraucht hat.
Er hat Häuser gebaut,
statt Filme und Musik zu kaufen.
Er hat mit dem Geld
seine Häuser gebaut
und ging als Flüchtling
nach Holland, hat sich abgesetzt.
Als er während dem Ramadan
in Dschibuti feiern wollte,
haben sie ihn
am Flughafen eingesperrt.
Jetzt dauert es eine Weile,
bis der neue Chef eingearbeitet ist.
Sie hatten eine Zwischenlösung,
jetzt gibt es einen neuen Chef.
Wenn sich die Gelegenheit ergibt,
werde ich es ihm vorstellen.
Beim anderen habe ich es probiert,
aber er hatte das Geld selbst
verbraucht. That's the problem.
Ein paar Tage später.
* Elektronische Reggae-Klänge *
Ich fahre jetzt
mit der Fähre nach Dschibuti.
Denn ich habe einen Termin bekommen
beim Fernsehen RTD,
um unsere Sachen vorzustellen.
Das hat sich jetzt ergeben.
Ich habe jemanden in Tadjoura
auf der Strasse getroffen,
von dem ich weiss,
dass er beim Fernsehen arbeitet.
Ich sagte,
es gebe ja einen neuen Direktor,
ob er mir nicht
dessen Telefonnummer hätte.
Er meinte,
der Direktor sei sein Freund.
Und die Sachen, die ich mache,
seien super, ich solle kommen.
Also die grosse Chance für Sie.
- Extrem.
Die Reise zum Nationalfernsehen
in die Hautstadt Dschibuti
des gleichnamigen Landes
dauerte einen halben Tag.
Nun geht sie hoffungsvoll
zum vereinbarten Termin.
Dann die Ernüchterung: Weiter als
in den Warteraum kommt sie nicht.
Ein paar Minuten später -
draussen vor der TV-Station.
Passiert ist gar nichts.
Wir gingen rein,
aber die Leute waren nicht dort,
weil der Präsident heute Nachmittag
an den Lac Assal musste.
Der Direktor und alle
mussten dorthin.
Im Büro war niemand.
Was mache ich?
Ich schaue, dass ich
einen nächsten Termin bekomme.
Irgendwann wird es klappen,
da bin ich mir sicher.
Seit diesen Aufnahmen
sind ein paar Monate vergangen.
Cornelia Frey steht inzwischen
auch mit anderen Fernsehstationen
in Kontakt.
Man sei begeistert von ihrer Soap,
sagt die Lebenskünstlerin.
Doch verkaufen
konnte sie die Filme bisher nicht.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
M. Gassner, L. Thomann - 2020